مقيدين ومعصوبي الأعين، حتى أن البعض
جردوا في هذا الفيديو من سخرية
الجنود الإسرائيليين الذين يسيئون إلى
العمال الفلسطينيين من غزة المحتجزين في إسرائيل ويسخرون منهم بعد
أيام قليلة من بداية
الحرب عند معبر كوم أبو سالم. الرجال ينتظرون
بفارغ الصبر على أمل أن
يكون أبناء والد إخوتهم من بين
العمال الفلسطينيين  الذين
أعادهم الجيش الإسرائيلي أخيرًا إلى غزة،
وتم إلغاء تصاريح الآلاف من قطاع غزة والعمال مثل هؤلاء الرجال
بعد هجوم حماس في 7 تشرين الأول/أكتوبر،
ولكن مع عدم وجود خيار
للعودة إلى ديارهم، حاول العديد منهم الفرار إلى
الضفة الغربية المحتلة فقط  ليتم
احتجازنا بعد ذلك، قيدوا أيدينا خلف
ظهورنا وعصبوا أعيننا واقتادونا إلى
حافلة. لا أعرف إلى أين أخذونا، ولكن
كان هناك ما يقرب من اثنين إلى 300
عامل من عمال جارين محتجزين هناك، وكان
بعض الرجال هنا ضعفاء بشكل واضح ومع
كل منهم  عبر المزيد من قصص
سوء المعاملة وحتى التعذيب، قال رجل لشبكة
CNN إنه شهد استخدام
الصدمات الكهربائية على
الأشخاص، ووضعونا في أقفاص مثل الكلاب،
وضربونا وأهانونا، ولم
يهتموا إذا كنت مريضًا أو مصابًا، حتى أن بعض
الرجال ماتوا  الطريق إلى هنا لأنهم
تعرضوا للضرب والصدمات
الكهربائية
[الموسيقى]
كل يوم شعروا وكأنهم الموت، كانوا
يعطوننا خيارًا لنتقاسمه
بين ستة أشخاص وقطعة
خبز صغيرة، ولم يتمكن مسؤول أمني إسرائيلي من
تحديد ما إذا تم استخدام أساليب الصدمات الكهربائية
لكنه قال لشبكة CNN إن الجيش الإسرائيلي على
علم بالعديد من حوادث الانتهاكات
ضد كل من العمال في غزة
والفلسطينيين في الضفة الغربية المحتلة،
مضيفًا أن هذه الحالات يتم
التعامل معها بجدية من خلال
إجراءات تأديبية قيل إنها اتخذت ضد
العديد من الجنود الذين تم التعرف عليهم في مقطع
فيديو على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي ولكن المنظمات غير الحكومية  يقول العاملون في
جمعية الأسير الفلسطيني إن هذه
قضية نظامية مع وجود القليل من الضمانات القانونية بدلاً
من
الفلسطينيين. لقد تلقينا
شهادات مروعة مباشرة. أخبرني أنهم
لم يرتكبوا أي خطأ، ولم يتم توجيه اتهامات إليهم
بأي شيء، ومع ذلك تم توجيه الاتهام إلى العديد منهم.  تم
استجوابهم وتعذيبهم بشكل منهجي، وتعرضوا للإيذاء والضرب
الوحشي،
وواجهوا جميع أنواع التجريد من الإنسانية
والإهانات في الضفة الغربية المحتلة، ولا يزال
هناك الآلاف من عمال الرب الذين تقطعت بهم
السبل يائسين من أجل لم شملهم مع
أحبائهم الذين يصلون كل يوم من أجل
سلامتهم، وكان م يعمل في إسرائيل مع
ابنه رفيق لكنه لم يره أو يسمع
منه منذ
شهر تقريبًا ولا أعرف أين هو سواء
كان في السجن أو ميتًا، إنه ابني
طوال حياتي، لقد جاء إلى هنا للعمل
ليتمكن من إطعام أطفاله.  لم يكن هنا
للانضمام إلى أي قتال، ولم يكن هنا لإثارة
المشاكل، ولكن مثلما توجد مخاوف على
أولئك الذين ما زالوا مفقودين في هذا المركز، فإن
هناك أيضًا معاناة لا توصف على
سلامة أفراد الأسرة في وطنهم في
غزة.  عائلتي الآن منتشرة في جميع أنحاء
غزة، لقد اضطروا جميعًا إلى مغادرة
مخيم جباليا للاجئين بسبب
الغارات الجوية عندما تمكنت من الوصول إليهم، كل ما
أسمعه هو البؤس كل يوم، وهي
كارثة أخرى منذ أسابيع يعاني منها العديد من هؤلاء الرجال.
لم يعد هناك أي اتصال مع عائلاتهم، لقد
تغيرت غزة التي تركوها وراءهم إلى
الأبد، ولكن بالنسبة لأولئك الذين يعيشون الآن عبر
الحدود، فإن الارتياح الناتج عن إطلاق سراحهم من
الاحتجاز ولم شملهم مع أحبائهم أمر
واضح، لكن الكثيرين لم
يعودوا ولا يزال الآلاف عالقين في
الضفة الغربية المحتلة وغيرها.  مازال
مفقود